who will talk about something a little
different for us which we all are
excited to learn from mean field games
thank you very much uh should I um
negotiate for my four minutes now or
later
well you can negotiate what you want the
question is how hungry people are so yes
hunger I agree okay so
um
I'd like to sincerely thank the
organizers for the invitation to uh to
speak here
um and I'd like to make clear around the
start that my uh uh this is work with uh
ranel fogan chondum who is a research
fellow here in the audience in the back
row uh and uh mini Huang okay with our
affiliations there are affiliations and
our grant agencies okay so our program
is uh first introduced large population
systems and mean field game equilibria
networks uh go past the networks and
graphons uh then present graph on me for
game systems and gmfg equilibria uh
introduce the notion of critical nodes
in in uh the case of a linear quadratic
gaussian graph on mean field games then
given a motivation for what I'm calling
embedding and then time allowing uh
discuss uh some uh research in progress
work in progress uh with some ideas for
uh embedded graph phones okay so uh
um so the fundamentals of neutral Game
Theory
for next a couple of slides
um so we're interested in a large
populations of agents that are uh
control uh they are States
through the stochastic differential
equations for the evolution of their
states and in the uh the notation is
that an agent will be denoted script A
some eye where the population n is as I
say will be going to infinity
and the states will be RN value
so uh so an agent I in a population n
has a state Evolution equation given by
this stochastic differential equation
where uh that its state evolves
according to its control but the drift
term is uh impacted by the states of the
other agents in the system and these are
averaged and summed over the other
agents in the system so and then we have
a noise intensity term and here a brown
in motion so annotations we have a
complete filtered probability of space
so this is time so it's a population
and the uh initial the that uh the
initial data will be the initial states
of the system that we have the standard
Brownian motions uh over the interval 0
to T with T's evolving and the
population size n so the the initial
states are independent identity
distributed L2 and independent of the
family of independent Browning motions
so it is a symbol you appear in your
stochastic differential equation and I
don't see you sorry so U sub ion I don't
see you in your attention
is going to be the control and there's
going to be defined in on later sides
thank you very much as uh functions of
the observations which are permitted to
the agent which will vary depending on
the uh on the problem definition
so uh the the cost of performance
function for each for a generic agent
using game three notation will depend
upon the ice agent's control and the
controls of all the agents except the if
agent and this will be with in a
standard uh uh uh stochastic control
framework will be the uh expectation of
the integral of the average of the costs
here again which are which are average
with respect to the influence of the
other agents in the system so notice
this is UI and this is your control that
will uh influence this uh that will
influence the positive cost here
incurred by this influence from the
other agents
yeah now the um the way that large
populations are handled is through the
machine plus of equations the idea is
that uh that for the agents are in that
if you take a a large population of
agents that are applying the same
control and are indistinguishable except
for their Brownian paths then the uh
then this uh uh uh behavior of the of
the other uh sample paths but then uh
will then aggregate into a measure which
will which will govern uh the evolution
of the generic state so we have here
that the the the that now we're just
looking at one agent which regards as
the generic agent in the population and
then here when they're all applying the
the same control over the sample parts
then what we're going to have here is
that this that this the drift term will
then be expressed as a limit when the
measure exists when a measure exists the
question of course it does is set up
have a solution so the conditions for a
machine vessels equations is a part of
the description uh is a part of the
problem formulation
so we can regard this as a as a
markovian system where we've got the uh
when there's a solution where the uh
where the measure of the population
where the measured mu describing the
population state distribution will
evolve according to a McCain blast of
equation
and an individual agent will evolve uh
with the population measure in the drift
term and its own individual Brownian
path
so the question of course is does such a
solution exist and the the standard
conditions will be Ellipsis continuity
of the function f so uniformly in the
controls the standard uh standard
conditions so we have a similar
representation you see previously we had
this integration over the uh over the uh
uh costs of the other that your your
individual costs were influenced by the
behavior of the other agents and we see
that when there's an exchangeability of
the other agents we have the major mu of
the population and your con influencing
it with your control you so the question
always is does there exist does there
exist as this stable measure for the
population
under the controls it's being used
so now the question is of the
information pattern that's used by the
individual agents who have two
completely different setups one is the
uh one is here we describe the uh Sigma
field generated by the state and initial
condition of the ice agent so this would
be the the individual Agency information
pattern it sees its trajectory so it
describes this fin adapted controls
adaptation mean meaning measurable As
Time increases so
um plus uh uh so this the the control
the local control meaning the individual
control is the
is going to be a controls adapted to
this in this uh uh sample path your own
sample path plus knowledge of system
parameters now of course knowledge is
not a mathematical hypothesis so it
means function of and so the the your
controls here are permitted to be
functions of the system parameters when
when solving an optimal control problem
of the game theory problem so now the
information for mean field control
systems in
um in for when we're looking at control
will be that the the information pattern
for the single by definition controller
will be the paths of all of the agents
so this is the the centralized control
or an individual controller who's
permitted to observe all parts of the
agent
so the the fundamental notion of
non-cooperative game equilibria is the
following so that uh as I'm sure most of
you are aware that a family of controls
you Alpha adapted to uh lock eye local
information generating Epsilon Nash
equilibrium with respect notice to the
individual costs if relay your lateral
control or utilizing the Global
Information pattern satisfies uh this
property uh so by definition a
unilateral move against the population
of Agents which who are utilizing Nash
strategy cannot yield a benefit of
moment Cylon for the unilateral agent
notice that this agent is unilateral is
permitted to use the Global Information
whereas the individual agents here are
are the the the uh apart from the uh uh
from the unilateral agent these guys are
all you see the that without the super
zero you're restricted to
the prescribed adapted controls to your
local information uh the unilateral
agent gets to use all the control there
are various ways of of
specifying Epsilon and Nash equilibria
but this is fairly General this is quite
a general one so we get quite a strong
result now so what do the superscript
zero sorry the super zero is simply is
whoops uh that's going to be a typo here
sorry the zeros should be Alphas thank
you very much so so and then rephrase
what does the superscripts alpha mean so
this distinguishes yes so so this just
distinguishes the family all these guys
are local thank you for catching the the
typo so the only guy that's not local is
the is the unilateral guy so everybody
moves according to every local
information yes everybody else
okay so
um
now
um
that uh game theorists tell us that the
the Nash equilibria
um are very uh tricky things namely uh
very simple problems Nash equilibrium
simply may not exist and uh on the other
hand when NASA group do exist there can
be a multiplicity of them and the
question is which ones to choose and to
compare between them so it's a very so
Network it's quite a slippery business
you'll be uh happy to hear that under
the conditions that we'll be uh giving
we have you the existence and uniqueness
of our national equilibrium okay so oh
by the way when Epsilon is equal to zero
we have the standard Nash equilibrium
okay and the zero should be read either
of the zeros or the zero itself is
that's not the the point that it's the
it's the unilateral move which is the
key issue here okay now if we go to the
the team graphs of representation of the
uh of the uh of the infinite population
equations
and if it is the case uh that there
exists a uh payoff function for each
agent so we're looking here at
exchangeable agents so this is a generic
agent
then the generic agent will will be
solving a stochastic control problem and
this is the key move of mean field game
theory as again which distinguishes it
from standard uh classical Game Theory
if you wish that by going to the
infinite population
situation if Solutions exist then an
individual agent playing against the
mass doesn't see other agents it really
sees a population distribution and so
it's playing against the random
environment which will involve which
will evolve uh deterministically
according to the uh Focus Planck
equation here
so
so a few questions coming yes the
microphone's illuminated
I am notices so why would this thing be
even differentiable
so we haven't put any assumptions on
here at all this is this is pre uh pre
mathematical analysis it says here
formally and so by formally we're
allowed to write down the limit
equations which means if an infinite
population it would satisfy okay so this
is formally so the the key Point here is
that is that
is that in contrast to the great
difficulty of solving uh finite
population uh uh game problems
stochastic game Problems by going to the
infinite population limit you get a
soluble problem because it turns into a
stochastic control problem this is the
key move the point is that in order to
get this stochastic control problem you
need to solve for the population measure
and the population measure corresponds
to the major governing a generic agent
because we're in taking exchangeable
agents here and that will evolve
according to the fopper Planck equation
so the heart of the matter is that is to
solve these two linked uh partial
differential equations well each agent
is contributing to the generation of a
population
measure which then govern which then
regenerates it then governs its own
behavior and
it it
governs the problem which it is solving
and this whole business must move
forward
over the window of time now the what is
the actual best response control well
it's it's given by as in the standard
stochastic control uh Way by in by the
improvisation of you over a compact set
where where eight here uh
informalization of the hamiltonian where
this is the hamiltonian so this is
standard optimal control theory except
for the fact that one's got here the
machine verse of uh feature to the drift
and the controls and once got here zero
uh here we've got zero terminal
conditions so can I formalize it a
little bit more in sort of the Vega
language just to see as I understand so
you have this
you have this control which which now is
sort of a continuous function which
controls sort of all agents and then I
want no no this is the control you see
this is an individual generic agents uh
equation you see this is the the oh I
see one genetic agent it is controlling
its equation you see it's the masses
only appear through the measure move and
in fact it's a specific point that that
the individual agents control is the arc
imp of the hamiltonian and that depends
upon time its state its state only and
the measure governing the mass
okay and notice that though that that
the genetic agents control
and the mass measure uh goes into the
evolution of its individual uh uh
distributions and there's the P here
again but of course it that that that
density uh is the assumed to exist
density of the measure of the mass
population so that's the the Golden
Circle which has to be closed right okay
right so it's a measure mu describes the
distribution of the controls of the
population the states
so I really try to understand this word
control so okay so who has control I'm
only is and H and have control over
myself but yes yes that's right the the
individual agent the individual agent uh
uh uh you see here in the infinite
population situation the individual
agent you will control its drift
and it subject to its evolving State and
the evolving state of the population but
that is also its distribution because of
the hypothesis of this but that's a
little what I don't quite understand so
the way I imagine a Continuum of Agents
is that each agent has a strategy right
I have a distribution of strategies over
this Continuum of agency Commandments
and then I as an individual agent am
supposed not to benefit by deviating
from the distribution that just assigned
to me that's right that's right but now
you say mu is not a distribution of con
of the control of States some states so
think of it as let me think of it in
financial terms if we if we must uh so
it would be that that each individual is
playing in a market uh the individual
has its its capital resources or
whatever
um or the funds that it can spare
um so then it's playing individually in
them in in the market against the the
distribution of the population everybody
else in the same position they're
playing against the the market but
they're also generating the markets
right so therefore actually the
distribution of the state is actually
generated by the distribution of the
strategy of the agents yes
yes in the end I think I I can say yes
to that paraphrase without finding
myself in a contradiction in three
slides times okay so so the question is
so then we have this uh uh a formal set
of equations here notice that we have
the the evolution of the individual
agent is as we've been saying here that
here we've got the uh now this is that
the equations are under the what's
called a best response control in game
three not an optimal control although in
this case the trick is that it's been
calculated by Optimal stochastic control
so does this okay can can this work so
subject to technical conditions which
are what so the the U is compact
literally it's about in this conditions
on all of the functions or this are this
is R to the r to the n in fact in
general at the end uh the the states and
the if you look at the arguments of F
and the existence of unique continuous
minimizer of the hamiltonian
right which which is now the continuity
there uh involves a a Vassar Stein uh uh
Criterion because you're working with
respect to the the the the the the the
measures then the McCain class of the
Keen uh the neem field game equations
have a unique solution with the Nash
equilibrium generated by the best
response control and that's a key point
that there exists a unique solution
um now the the techniques used by mini
Huang Royal malame and myself uh in 2006
that these actually Banner contraction
argument uh so um and in the and this is
why I'm summarizing the conditions we
use which were the compactness lipsticks
found in this and so on uh the the uh
simultaneous and independent discovery
of this uh of the mean field game
equation Theory uh by Leslie and Leon
um use a takatani fixed Point theorem
but they don't get uniqueness so then
that that's almost a sub-discipline in
the Paris school because there's
something called the the Leslie Leon
monotonicity conditions and that's
actually got a whole literature with it
which generates uh a criteria for
uniqueness sorry just one quick question
so
um it's a unique nationally equilibrium
point the steady state solution for the
focal Planck equation or not do we have
steady state Solutions well the uh time
here is finite so there is a theory for
steady state Solutions indeed we're
sticking to finite time intervals here
okay so um
radio and um uh both but uh with uh mini
and rolong we also proved a uh Epsilon
Nash result and this this is the
justification for the applications of
the whole business
because uh you could you see here
that the that
um that the uh uh that this this What's
Happening Here is that the agents are
all using here zero really does mean the
superscript zero it really does mean
solution to the Hamilton jacket
development equation the solution to the
the hot to the MFG equations here
um all the agents are using the solution
to the infinite population equations
but they're using them in the finite
population setting
and that's why at only uh it was the
cost of Epsilon where obscilla where
Epsilon will go to zero as a population
size goes to Infinity so this the
implication of this is that you solve
the equations at Infinity which is going
to be uh these are the the the issue of
solving these partial differential
equations or in a linear quadratic
gaussian case a a an array of of uh
linear equations plus a ricardi equation
which is completely standard
and then you apply in your finite
network setting finite population excuse
me Network's coming a bit later in the
final population setting you then apply
the the infinite population controls for
a cost that you know which here will be
going down actually like one one over
root n basically
um uh for a cost which you can estimate
the alternative would be to try to solve
all of you to solve for the Nash problem
for the for the finite population in
which could be quite large knowing that
even for quite medium numbers it's an
impossible task okay so this is why uh
this is actually the key reason that uh
meanfield game theory has become so
popular is that you can use it as a path
around complexity uh by the cost of
solving the mental game equations in an
otherwise attractable intractable
situation
so the okay networks and gratons okay
now the um the classical info game model
which you've just seen I mean there are
thousands of papers on this so this
isn't even an indication of a survey of
the topic these are just the elements so
the key variables are simply average
when it's a mass they put a role in the
behave with a large population system
the only averages you've seen here are
one over n sum right so which is really
equivalent to a uniformity assumption
namely the individual agents the
distributed of the nodes of a
large-scale network completely connected
all edges have equal weight and so on
okay in the uniform uniformity
assumption often doesn't hold uh May
hold locally approximately but not
globally so now we get to motivation
slides one is a
transportation clusters over the Earth
um this is pre-covered for sure
um where you've got a density of of
flight paths over Europe uh North
America and and Asia where you may have
local denseness but obviously you do not
have Global denseness uh a fact which I
think this audience will uh appreciate
so this is at a planetary level and here
we have at the level of the United
States again uh here you may have
denseness locally to a degree but
globally you clearly do not so this
would be the invitation and this is the
invitation we thought to use grappling
Theory so that we could look at large
complex networks which were not uniform
and so try to and try to exploit and use
the the power of Craftman Theory now
this audience really doesn't need to see
the iconic uh uh
um uh evolution of the uniform
attachment graph sequence
of uh all um even to read the definition
of a bounded symmetric with a very
commercial function uh that a graph one
is a bounded symmetric the vague
measurable function on the unit squared
2 for instance the unit interval
and its uh interpretation
so uh and again you don't need to uh to
really see a definition of the cut
distance or the definitions the metric
except here the tricky business of
course of the information of all measure
preserving bijections which is something
later on that we don't want to do so so
uh and then the key the key theorem of
course being the uh the the compactness
of the space of graphons under the
current metric okay now so what we so
now what we want to do is do a do um
meme field games over complex networks
where complex here means non-uniform
yeah so if so uh so we know now what
this happens you've seen before but now
with connections over networks as well
so here we have depiction of states of
all agents um in a bunch of clusters so
we've got these clusters of of Agents
which you can think which I invite you
to think of as being at nodes in the
network
giving a total population uh which will
be the sum of the populations at the
number of agents at the individual
um uh uh nodes uh if it's a scalar that
would also be the number of the
individual states
um the agents in the cluster I then face
uh two coupling terms uh one will be the
local clapping term at zero which is our
standard mean field game
connections within your node and then we
have the connections over the network
which will be of the same sort notice
it's your control interferes here the
other guy's controls influence their
steep Evolution at their nodes whether
the UI actually appears there is not not
actually significantly in some problems
it may be and then what's going on at
the at the you see the this is the Jace
this is the Jace agent in the elf
cluster
so they're averaging out over the
population size population size
um in the elf cluster then that cluster
influences the impact on the this uh the
global drift impact on the ice agent by
then being averaged over the graph
connections between the elf cluster and
the ice cluster that that is the in
which the if agent resides and then this
is all appropriately normalized so it's
your so you have a network but you also
has input have sort of set clusters of
Agents right so that this is the Agents
of each of each of the nodes
can I think of the cluster as a ball of
radius r or is your cluster just put my
class talk contain some people in Russia
uh so and is it interesting that you
don't know introduce the notion of
distance and Metric of course which
doesn't exist here however graph so I
have a Distance on the graph so um so at
this point we're just using the standard
indexing and these will be disjoint you
know to answer your question that these
will be disjoint populations at this
this at the distinct clusters disjoint
populations
is that another input of the system so
you have a graph and you have a
collection of clusters foreign the
Clusters will reside at the individual
nodes in the network
and they will be the populations sitting
at the separate nodes oh I see so the
agents yes so I think of the notes as
containing many agents each of them
exactly and the number of Agents
probably also goes to Infinity yes okay
that's right Infinities everywhere yes
that's right so um so then then I maybe
this answers your question more clearly
that the evolution of the ice agent will
be given by its a standard mean field
now familiar mean field Evolution
locally plus the impact uh weighted by
the uh
mitigated weighted by The Edge weights
in the network and then at each of the
separate nodes
which will be like the elf for instance
here the elf node its local population
will generate this drift influence which
will then be and then I'm repeating
myself the average through the network
and then impacts the The Ice agent
notice that this is all the drift term
and it's still only got its individuals
uh brand new motion
okay
is that has that made it clear yeah okay
and so then we just then we pack that up
into this uh term into this notation
yeah uh uh we do the analogous trick
trick uh the the make the analogous uh
uh summation uh where the actual costs
your costs locally at the ice for the
ice agent in its uh plus the CI is then
this normalized weighted
weighted sum of the average costs
impacting you from the uh jth agent in
the elf cluster and then again you add
that up to the standard mean field term
and then you get the expression here
Okay so
uh so then what we're going to assume is
the number of notes in the graph tends
to Infinity extreme a unique graph on
limit
uh the subpopulations at each node will
turn to Infinity given a local mean
field at each node and then the global
set of mean Fields is denoted mu capital
G okay and we've denoting the the graph
font G Alpha Beta then we've got then
this repeats the uh terminology that
we've just been established so now what
we have with this expanded notation is
that the alpha the the alpha node in at
the at the that now the the alpha the
alpha now generates an alpha node and
this will be a generic agent in the
alpha node and this is all of the mean
Fields if they exist over the network in
so this will be so for every element of
the network so this is in the infinite
case so oh it should emphasize that this
is that here we've now passed through
the infinite Network infinite
populations and having an infinite
population each node in an infinite
Network
and so we're going to try and make the
same maneuver you see this was the
finite populations on a finite Network
then so once this notation is
established we then as in the meme field
situation passed to not only infinite
populations but an infinite Network
okay so so you see what happens uh here
is that is that uh that question yes
so in the infinite system what does a
point represent does it represent in the
prelimit a whole bunch of particles that
now became like one point in the
infinite system because in the pre-limit
you had like individuals who somehow had
their own clusters which are then
connected using yeah yeah so so the
situation is that the only individual
you can ever see is just one guy let's
say yourself yes and then if you then
what you see is that the individuals in
your node I mean in the limit yes
individuals in your node have just
turned into into a measure that's just
the population okay and the network
itself which you could see is a bunch of
edges before we went to the Limit yeah
which we assuming here is dense that's
turned into a dense uh uh uh graph on
lens Network and uh that of each of the
points in it right nodes each of those
at each of those resides again an
infinite population
I see so the in the graph on limit the
each point actually corresponds to a
collection of individuals in the
pre-limit is that right okay yeah but we
still retain the individuality of any of
any agent that we land on you see this
will we can still describe the the
evolution of an individual so this isn't
uh this is like you're really grabbing a
single molecule in the statistical
mechanics model you're really looking at
that at that molecule as it's influenced
by all of the mean field all of the of
the rest of it here we've got two layers
of infinity local populations infinite
exterior populations and the infinite
Network
happens
so would there be like an infinite
number of clusters and those all right
would there be an infinite number of
clusters yes yeah actually uncountable
yes right so there's and so there is
sort of an uncountable infinite product
of an of something which represents a
distributes the infinite Distribution on
the cluster so it's sort of zero one to
the r or something like that yes which
is your States okay again again I'm
going to risk it yeah I think I can
definitely respect yes you've got a
double infinity here for sure because
you have the Infinities at all of the
points namely infinite populations at
all of the points in the infinite
network is it obvious that all of this
is well defined I mean you have an
uncountable number of brownie emotions
right right yeah is there some
consistency between them or just IID
the the the the the parts are are
independent indeed these are independent
or different Alpha yes uh so uh
at indeed firstly at the other nodes of
course you don't see any motions I mean
all you've got is just the populations
locally you've got your you've got your
individual sample path contributing to
your local meeting field but it's I mean
the the this is a path governed by a
measure at each node
so um
uh so the uh so the question is um so
now we go to the mean field game the
graph on mean field game equations
so now this is
essentially a copy almost of the mean
field game equations
except that now we've got that now we
have parameterized by and by Alpha where
Alpha is ranging through the nodes of
the network okay and at each node we're
going to have we're going to have an
individual measure except that because
of that focusing of influences from
around the network we actually have all
of the measures at all of uh over all of
the nodes appearing in your individual
drift term here okay and the g Alpha
actually is is gonna is describes your
fiber in the graph on so these this is
the edges that that impact on you so um
now so now what we have is uh the the
focus that is the uh
Alpha indexed
um being field a focal Planck equation
the Hamilton Jacobi equation uh Alpha
indexed and uh the the uh the best
response is going to be is going to turn
out to be a function again only of of
your state only this is very this is
crucial for the for the actual
interpretation of the results but will
depend upon all of the other measures
and your your local mean field if if
this scheme has a solution okay so now
we have the existence and uniqueness
result for this uh uh situation so we
have here
so um so with menu in uh uh the papers
at the CDC and in the same Journal
control and optimization last year
there's uh uh our analysis of the
situation which uh which essentially for
again you compact uh boundedness of the
functions of all the functions that
you've seen uh lip shits conditions on
all functions together with the
existence of a unique continuous
minimize the hamiltonian it's the same
words that exists a unique Nash
equilibrium solution Now indexed by
Alpha ranging over the nodes of the
network okay okay and the feedback best
response strategy as I've just said in
my last slide now uh uh depends upon
again crucially only your local state
and time and the solution to the whole
works so this is that
the the objection here could be that
I've been
um promoting means to field game theory
on the grounds that you replace 300 000
equations of a hundred thousand
competitors in some Market situation
by six equations describing three states
for the vocal Bank equation and three
states now have turning the equation so
so this enormous reduction of complexity
is what makes it which is what makes it
work and I replace and now I've gone to
a situation of an uncountable number of
those problems so where's the advantage
but the point is that that the
complexity here depends upon the the
complexity of the graph arm
because the variety of of of of Dynamics
at the at the nodes all of which you've
got to solve depends upon how
complicated the graphon is and you'll
see that in for simple graphons in fact
you can solve this setup just as you
could have Solve IT solved the mean
field game equations before
so first we get the existing uniqueness
result then uh subject to so what comes
next of course is
um is uh the Epsilon Nash result so
so there's a graph convergence
assumption which
um which uh requires
which currently this is our best
assumption or condition which is that so
that this is when you've got um MK MK is
the number of of nodes uh the that um
that this normalization of the uh of the
the weight in the case graph of the
connection between the iPhone JS cluster
that it's different now there's a point
there's an issue here which uh need to
address which is that this will be you
take a midpoint on the interval
corresponding to the uh to the uh chosen
agent and then you integrate the graph
on function over the interval that
corresponds to the J J cluster so
there's so you're in integrating over
this sort of wedge in the in the uh if
you're in if we're integrating over all
betas you'd then be integrating looking
out from your node over everybody so
this is just looking out from your node
just the part of the fiber in the graph
form that corresponds to the JS agent
okay so that interval right so then
um
so okay that's that this is somewhat
stronger than just the graph limit
convergence right so yeah this is an
it's an extra condition to make this
work yeah yeah so yeah
so the so subject to that convergence
okay so that in their in the ice cluster
the agent uh so in the finite setup the
agent I will be using now there's a
there's a a an additional Point here
when you're trying to control on large
networks which is that when you go to
the applying the uh applying your
infinite property control in the mean
field game setup there's no problem
problem without approximation you're
just the ith agent and then you compute
the the the the the infinite population
solution and just use it the question
when you come down from the infinite
graph and you it it is how you actually
communicate between the infinite graph
and your local graph
so there you look at the actual
construction
use this midpoint use these midpoint
intervals and then you can get your get
your approximation so then the answer
the answer is using the midpoint
controls now we've got a double limit so
as you that for sufficiently large
populations and a sufficiently la and a
a graph sufficiently far along the
sequence for the convergence that you've
seen to take to to be close enough then
you get your Epsilon Nash property okay
and as I've emphasized this is this is
what allows you to apply in principle uh
your uh uh infinite
simple computed Solutions in your finite
setting
so the the the next so the next topic uh
is that we're interested in critical
nodes for graph on mean for game systems
so
I assume let's assume a graph I mean
field game system has matched values so
let's assume that the problems are
soluble and let's assume that they're
differentiable okay oh by the way the
differentiability that you that we got
earlier with respect to time and space
of the Nash values was it was a result
of the application or the theory of
partial differential equations that
those Solutions indeed had Solutions of
course proving they have Solutions
involves
approving establishing that
differentials exist
so the
um then Alpha is a critical node for the
dmfg system if the local National value
stationary conditions hold namely if at
your node if you differentiate with
respect to movement of the node namely
to say it's partial differential with
respect to the node index then you get
zero and then you get a locally a
stationary value okay you have a clear
stationary value
Alpha now
so Alpha is a node index here now if I
is a node index in the limit right yes
and now so you to some extent assume you
have differential so that is you you
need a differentiability with respect to
the
index of the graph form which is usually
something we absolutely don't discuss
and don't have it's a graphic Theory so
now you need a graph compared if you've
said that because that's the whole
research in progress last 10 minutes in
my talk
so I didn't pay him to say that
well I mean you kept do you negotiated
five minutes which are almost over but
we really had a lot of questions do we
want to give him should we vote do we
give him five more
okay so you get you get now five and a
half more minutes okay thank you very
much
um
uh okay so uh that okay so the firstly
this illustrates that this illustrates
how that the fact that you can solve
these equations
um so in the classic uh this is work by
uh uh renelle and and then later
developments of it with uh with uh
schwanco uh in the in the audience if
you take the standard linear system or
scalars standard quadratic cost
functions okay
and notice the the uh the drift here
does not involve for Simplicity the mean
field although off very often we will
have the individual states that the
alpha node push around by the mean field
for sure okay and in fact the the that
that more than just the impact of all
the mean Fields here we've got the here
we've got the global mean of the mean
field in the sense that you take the
means of the measures uh at the all the
beta nodes uh Infinity of them then you
weight them by the graph one then you
get the local impact ZL for G and that
goes in the cost function and this cost
function where you're trying to track
the mass behavior is the standard is a
standard mean field game a a
performance function so now you uh you
could the by solving as I've advertised
the stochastic control problem for the
individual agent against the mean field
which is here just represented by its
mean
uh then and then applying the
consistency condition that the resulting
measure on the alpha agent is
that you get is exactly the law that you
assumed in the first place then and what
you do that results in solving uh the
recut standard ricardy equation of
linear quadratic control theory uh
here's your control depending upon your
state the solution to ricardi equation
and an offset which is driven by the uh
that by the mean by the deterministic
mass mean field coming in on your node
like this okay so now you can actually
show calculations here so hit this to
the point that we want to get to that
um that if you take for instance two uh
the classic base cases the Eros Rene
graph okay and so if there's if if
people if the agents nodes are connected
by either trainer then then it turns out
that the means of those weighted means
that you've seen are stationary the uh
the controls will turn out to be
stationary and the actual uh Nash value
turned out to be stationary here on the
uniform attachment graph again this is
to not only to show you the the the the
application of the uh ideas here but to
show that you can actually solve these
equations in the linear quadratic
gaussian case
um here they only know that turns out to
be stationary
for the for the mean and then for the
value is the root node so here of course
this is heavy with interpretation namely
that if you want to minimize your cost
and you're playing in a in a game where
connectivity matters which it does here
then put yourself at the root of a
uniform attachment graph and you're
going to minimize your costs most and
that's and that is illustrated by
computation okay so um and uh so this is
the proposition that in fact that in
fact you also get that that for this lqg
situation you can actually show that
you've got stationarity
um at the at those um
uh at the uh that when you had those
critical meme uh meme filled nodes they
were also critical uh uh uh here so the
um now the in the remaining
um
2.3 minutes
um that the uh the the the here it is
that
the issue is investing by real numbers
okay that and the major preserving uh
bijection because there's no geometric
significance to this and so the the
differentiation is not meaningful uh
what's more you can't just you cannot
map down to the the the real interval
um the that uh open subsets of euclidean
space from your higher dimensions of the
other uh if the if you start with
embedded uh uh uh graph models you've
got no hope of not of getting a a
homeomorphism let alone a diffiomorphism
if you take them to the unit interval so
um what we want to do is to embed our
our graphs starting off by embedding the
vertices and to do that
um that I came up with a scheme which I
call the taxons which is an embedding of
the nodes and and a a proving that uh
that uh these are giving a well sort of
condition free of having limits to
sequence of vertices in a box so in your
unit and dimensional unit box so we can
embed athletic sets without going
through the details here of course
um that we have a that actually
essentially paralleling the paralleling
the proof scheme for the compactness of
graphene spaces in uh the The Leverage
monograph
um one can show with the modification of
it the existence of of limit measures
for the vertex sequences and if those
measures have densities then you have
got a sets on which you can support your
differentiation
and then you can play the same
game
on the product space with the edges
planted in it and again using this a
modification sorry this is just look
like a massive words here using a
modification again of the compactness
proof
and the compactness proof you can then
actually get measures which govern the
graph limits so and they're sitting in
space we've got a differentiation so
then we have a framework then we have a
framework that actually differentiating
in a meaningful way meaningful way
uh in meaningful way actually
of course solving the dmfd equations
didn't require such a differentiation
but now we have these Solutions and it
embedded we can in our
uh uh uh with a straight face
differentiate with respect to no
position
that's working progress
okay so I think we like you may have
used
okay thank you very much I think we
should push questions to the lunch break
or tea
thank you very much for your attention